I guess I just have to accept now that
all white men are just awful at
everything and they suck and myself
included I should just hang my head and
shame for the rest of my life it's a
strange sort of offering that they're
giving us now where we're gonna actively
hate you as a art form we're gonna make
our business to make you feel awful
about yourself and if you dare to push
back on that and reject the offering
that we're giving you then we just label
you as a bigot or a reactionary or
whatever stupid term we label people
with these days
what is your background tell me how you
end up getting interested in critiquing
movies
oh gosh
um
right what's the short version here
um yeah I mean I guess like from being a
a young kid like I was always just
fascinated by movies and I was
fascinated by like the the way that the
stories worked you know the way that
they would introduce us to the different
characters the way that they were
structured so that you know you had that
well-defined like uh build up of action
and then the the sort of catastrophe
that leads you to the lowest point and
then the big resolution at the end to
give you that dramatic high that
finishes it off like I remember being
even as a kid I started to recognize
that pattern in movies and it was
something that kind of interested me
um and it led me into wanting to do
storytelling of my own eventually and so
I got into writing novels that sort of
thing
um and obviously YouTube came along and
um
you know I was interested in the idea of
starting to break that down and critique
things a little bit
um you know my my early videos were
shockingly amateurish but you know it
was just fun it was a fun like
experience to get used to it get used to
editing videos all that sort of stuff
um yeah obviously I took a break from
that to actually focus on my writing
career for a good long while uh and then
a few years ago I decided to come back
and start doing it again and uh gosh I
just uh really got into character one
time as the drunken critical Drinker I
think it was after a few glasses of Jack
and I noticed I was slurring my words
and I just thought what the hell I'm
just gonna I'm gonna embrace it and lean
into it and uh that video just went
viral man like within
a few days it had like a million views
and suddenly my channel exploded and
that's that's what got me started on the
path I'm on now I suppose so it worked
out the first video that uh that kicked
off
I think it was about
Captain Marvel
um so that would have been right three
years ago now
um it was
yeah I I think because there was such a
media circus around that movie
um you know all the the talk about oh
finally we're getting a female superhero
and all that nonsense and I just thought
gosh this is all a bit silly and um it
kind of really just conveniently forgets
all the great characters that we'd had
up until then and I thought I'll just do
a sarcastic video saying I totally agree
with this while showing you know all
these awesome female characters through
all the different decades and for
whatever reason that just absolutely
blew up so that was my that was my first
taste of YouTube success I suppose
I looked at an article earlier on that
identified the Divergence in Rotten
Tomatoes
uh critics and audience scores and they
have never been further apart on average
according to the data science that was
done by this so as an example critics
loved an audiences loathed Star Wars The
Last Jedi which was 49 divided and
audiences loved and critics loathed
Venom which was 51 divided in 2022 the
gap between audience and critic scores
on Rotten Tomatoes has become bigger
than ever audiences have given the top
10 movies on average score more than 19
points higher than critics by far the
biggest difference this Century the only
two of this year's 10 movies where
audiences and critics are even close was
top gun Maverick and the Batman what do
you think that says about the state of
modern movies
I think they're not making people happy
I think people are watching them and
they're coming away fundamentally
unsatisfied and the critics that I guess
they used to kind of trust because they
would generally agree on movies because
I think the actual quality of films was
better but 10 20 years ago uh now
they're diverging because they're
beginning to realize that uh these
critics that they used to trust are
basically just paid to give positive
reviews and you know it's in their
interest to be positive because it
allows them to keep getting access to
film premieres to getting all those
little lovely goody baskets and stuff
that Studios send you if you're a
professional critic uh and you know that
that's what they go on
um and so there's now this realization
of wow these people are really full of
crap and I can't trust their opinions on
anything uh and so yeah I'm glad that
it's finally happened I'm glad people
have woken up to like really how rotten
that entire industry is I think Rotten
Tomatoes is a good term for it
there is a situation though when critics
are poorly reviewing films and the
audience is reviewing a film well so
this isn't a case of the critics
cozying up to some studio what's going
on there
I think in those cases it may be a case
of ideological
um persuasion in that uh generally when
that happens in the movie World surely
not who would have thought
I think generally when that happens it's
a case of a movie which uh doesn't align
with the current uh ideology of
Hollywood and um audiences generally lap
that up because man most people are just
they're not left-wing they're not
right-wing they're just in the middle
and when they go to the movies they just
want to be entertained that's all they
want and when they get a movie that
gives them that uh they generally love
it but then the critics
they don't love it because it's not it's
not spouting the the ideology that
they've been taught that they have to uh
but they have to agree with and then
they have to promote at any cost and so
yeah that's generally when that happens
it's interesting right because movies
for a long time were a good vehicle that
could be used to put forward an
important social movement narrative it
was a way of communicating to the masses
in a entertaining in subtle way that
this is something that you might have to
think about but it does seem more and
more flagrant more and more mask off
less subtle and more
almost uh like being flagellated like
being whipped by the film
I I yeah I don't get it in a lot of
cases I don't get why people would want
to watch them you know it's uh what can
I liken it to
um
yeah I mean I suppose the classic
example is something like the Last Jedi
from Star Wars uh if you if you go watch
that it's like you know I guess I just
have to accept now that all white men
are just awful at everything and they
suck and that's just that myself
included you know so I should just hang
my head and shame for the rest of my
life uh yeah it's it's a strange
um
it's a strange sort of uh
offering that they're giving us now
where we're gonna actively
hate you as a as a art form you know
we're going to make our business to make
you feel awful about yourself and if you
dare to push back on that and uh and
reject the offering that we're giving
you uh then we get we will label you as
a bigot or uh reactionary or whatever
you know stupid term we label people
with these days uh there's no actual
engagement with criticism anymore and
it's uh it's a frustrating thing but
then again I feel like more and more
people are just kind of seeing through
that now they've like you say the mask
is off and
um it's becoming very obvious how biased
and you know uh tilted in One Direction
is uh I think you know that that TV show
that they kit that came out recently
Velma I don't know if you've heard about
that but it's it's like this weird uh
attempt to reboot the whole Scooby-Doo
thing that we watched when we were kids
you know the kids cartoon
um no it's told from the point of view
of Velma and it's all about like every
character has been race swapped
everyone's gay now uh the the only
character that's been kept as a white
guy is Fred who's now the butt of every
single joke he's an idiot uh he can't do
anything for himself all that stuff and
it's like it's like a parody
of uh of the kind of uh messages that
they were putting out you know a few
years ago uh but it's so over the top
and ridiculous that it's like every peop
every person from every side of the
argument is hating on it I just think
it's really funny
well I mean if you were a well-meaning
moderate left liberal person and this
was the popular media that was supposed
to represent your side I would be so
ridiculously embarrassed I I
it's worse to have your point of view or
your side of the aisle be misrepresented
by this like
woke It's Like A Parasite that's just
embodied what used to be quite a loved
institution Scooby-Doo was legendary
right when we were kids Scooby-Doo was I
think it was just it was it was just
innocent fun you know and I think that's
that's what people took as and now it's
like
God it from what I've heard because I
only watched the first couple episodes
and I was done but even then it's like
it's got 15 year old girls in the shower
room you know like full-on nude it's got
like
um Velma who's like again the same age
in a strip club it's like what are you
what are you showing us what are you
doing with this
and it's like I I have to question the
mindset of the people who have written
this and created it and the executives
that signed off on it this has got to be
borderline you know this is really
distasteful stuff now and it's like this
all came from a a goofy kids TV show
from the 1970s about like a bunch of
bunch of college students that went
around solving Mysteries like why why
are you doing this
well we've seen the same thing with
She-Hulk right that was sort of
pretty mask off in terms of how that got
repurposed and the worst one that I've
seen recently was uh Doctor Strange two
I watched that on a plane before anybody
on YouTube had had a chance to do a
summary explaining why I shouldn't watch
it even on a plane and I got sideswiped
by uh yeah I watched a little bit of
She-Hulk and then bailed out but I
watched all of Doctor Strange too
because I was literally trapped in a tin
box flying at 35 000 feet but uh yeah
you'll watch pretty much anything when
you're on a long-haul flight wouldn't
you correct
um but I mean it was it it's the same
tenor with that right it's I don't know
it's just not it doesn't feel subtle
anymore there's no progression to the
characters especially if they're female
or from a minority and this is something
that I really enjoyed talking to Baggage
Claim about which is that it patronizes
women because it basically makes them
out to be incapable of ever dealing with
any challenge they can't overcome
anything they are perfect as they are I
mean there's a moment in Doctor Strange
too where zombie Benedict Cumberbatch
goes back in time to tell America Chavez
the South American daughter of two women
that she just needed to believe in
herself all along
that is the running theme when it comes
to these female characters and it's such
an unhealthy message to send to people
um you know even like take an r a
personal opinions out of the equation
that it's like you know trying to make
out that women are just perfect at
everything which you know we're all
human none of us are perfect
um it's teaching people that you
shouldn't need to strive to improve
yourself you shouldn't need to struggle
and when you come across uh challenges
or adversity the rest of the world just
needs to accept that you're amazing the
way you are imagine if people took that
to heart and tried to take that lesson
out into the world and apply it to their
lives it would be disastrous for them
they would just get hit with like
failure after failure uh you know
it it's it used to be such a much more
inspiring message that movies gave you
about that the power of self-improvement
of of rising to challenges and
struggling uh and you know maybe failing
and making mistakes but learning from
them and becoming better as a result
um that was a great thing to teach
people because that's how you progress
in life you know
um so yeah to try and do that it's not
only is it patronizing but it's really
counterproductive for people
especially given that a lot of the
lessons that people learn about how to
exist in the world come from popular
media you know especially given that
these are movies that ostensibly are
supposed to help people who perhaps
don't come from the perfect sort of
background maybe they haven't had an
amazing parental household giving them
all of the worldly wisdom that they
should do to be able to navigate through
okay so you are going to in some regard
like as a movie studio be a surrogate
parent almost or like a sage or a
grandparent in some regard to pass down
these are some kind of
Timeless truths that you can hold on to
and the Timeless truth is if you're a 15
year old mixed race investigator coming
out of high school with a talking dog
for a friend
get naked in the shower and go to a
strip club
that seems to be the lesson
um and yeah like it's
again to talk about messaging in movies
you know as you said there there used to
be this acknowledgment that uh the the
older generation had wisdom to impart to
the younger generation who were just
coming up you know they can teach them
the lessons that they learned in their
lives and you know give them something
to to prepare them for the challenges
that they were going to face uh that was
a a Timeless kind of universal concept
because that's how people generally get
by in life you can learn things from
your elders
um but again there seems to be this
movement now in modern movies to do away
with that and say that uh the older
generation have nothing to teach you
there's nothing useful you can learn
from them uh you're just like I say
you're great the way you are people just
need to acknowledge your awesomeness
um and you know particularly if that
older Mentor type figure happens to be a
man yeah there's no way he's not allowed
to teach you anything uh and you you
touched upon this with um Multiverse of
Madness like Doctor Strange too
there was a bit in uh the TV show One
Division which is the one that just
leads into Doctor Strange
um and people were asking well how is he
not there surely that's exactly the kind
of situation he should be involved in
because he's he's a magic guy
and Kevin feige the guy who runs Marvel
said uh well it would look bad if we had
a white man coming in to show Wanda how
to use her powers
that's the mentality he's not allowed to
do that because he's the wrong sex and
he's the wrong ethnicity
that's the we're basically living with
like this this weird New Age like
segregationism in in movies there's
there's like a set of rules and laws
that these movies have to adhere to now
when it comes to their storytelling and
this is just one of the rules
can't have a guy especially a white guy
teaching a female character anything
valuable he has to be dumb and he has to
be useless and she has to be better than
him everything
fair enough but like that's it's like
trying to tell a story with with an art
with one arm type behind your back you
know you're crippling the The Writer's
ability to tell a good story because
you're putting so many rules on them to
to try and appease all the ridiculous
demands of all the people on social
media now who get offended by everything
that you [__] your ability to tell a
story
when it comes to getting Awards didn't I
hear you talk about the fact that you're
only eligible for uh certain Awards if
you have the right kind of
representation both in front of the
camera behind the camera in terms of the
studio and stuff
yeah the academy
um like for the Oscars um straight up
published their guidelines basically
saying you your movie isn't even
eligible to be considered for an Oscar
unless it's got X percentage of of uh
ethnic minorities X percentage of women
X percentage of LGBT people uh all of
that stuff that is now the defining
factors and whether or not your movie is
even eligible for consideration for an
award of any kind and again I just have
to ask like why
like how does that improve the quality
of the film by just demanding that
certain people have to be involved in it
you know it God forbid you would just
hire people based on how good they were
in other jobs
you know and that's not going to get any
better
yeah what so I'm going back to the
conversation especially around men
um
why do you think Hollywood hates men so
much at the moment
uh probably a guy named Harvey like that
was definitely part of it who who was
obviously you know he he got caught out
uh obviously did a lot of terrible
things and and rightly got uh you know
in prison for it
um but the result was this seismic you
know shock wave that went through
Hollywood and it just became from that
point uh we we can't have
we can't have men in sort of positions
of power we can't have uh like
traditional strong masculine men uh in
in lead roles anymore and if if you ever
get a character like that they almost
always become the butt of a joke you
know it's always like ah look at this
guy thinking he's like Macho Man or
whatever and then he feels at something
uh it's always the same like Thor
yeah yeah like Thor big muscly guy just
becomes an absolute goofy clown because
isn't it funny to laugh at them uh you
know how many times have you seen a man
get kicked in the balls in a in a Disney
movie it's funny isn't it it's really
funny when that happens it's not so
funny when it happens to you though and
again you know you reverse the genders
there like if you showed a woman getting
kicked in the crotch like suddenly it's
not funny anymore you know like the the
it would have been a thermonuclear
explosion on social media if that was
ever shown on a in a in a mainstream
movie particularly if it was shown for
Laughs it's not gonna happen but it's
okay when it happens to men you know
it's just this weird double standard and
I think it partly
you know a big part of it is a result of
like Harvey and all that crap
um and a part of it is just a a shift in
the kind of culture in Hollywood that I
think was perhaps happening anyway
um
they're just trying to this constant
drive to like redefine masculinity which
you know often means like getting some
skinny you know 14 year old dude and
putting them in a dress and like saying
this this is masculinity now like yeah
sure it is like whatever
um
but yeah that that kind of dual
almost pincer movement of like cultural
change within Hollywood and reaction to
to things that have been exposed within
their own ranks it's just been
um you know men masculine male heroes
are not a viable commodity in movies at
the moment you know uh but that's why
you get like something
I was just gonna say that's why when you
get the occasional movie that does dare
to show them they usually do really well
because people have been starved of this
stuff for years
what would be some examples of that like
Top Gun
probably yeah
yeah it's pretty good example
um yeah it was like it was a movie
that's combined all of those things
together like we were talking about you
know the the Aging mentor
who would normally be a subject of
mockery uh you know a different director
a different right area would have
portrayed Maverick as completely over
the hill and you know getting outclassed
by all these young
people who are faster and better than
him no this movie dared to say and it
was probably partly because Tom Cruise
and he's got an ego on him saying no he
still get it while he does and you know
what he's
got way more experience than you he's
been there and done that and he can kick
your ass if he wants to he's still able
to do that uh and look what it did 1.5
billion dollars it was the biggest movie
of the Year by far
and all these Marvel properties that
used to dominate and and you know
absolutely wipe the floor with
everything else they were trailing far
behind and it was I was very happy to
see that it pleased me
I so I watched I've flown a lot over the
last year so almost all of the movies
that I've seen have been on planes and I
really enjoyed Top Gun but I didn't
think it was ridic I would have given it
maybe a like a 7.5 probably an eight
probably an eight on the Tomato Meter I
think I would have given it so still
good but kind of shows that the bar
isn't exactly set superbly High
yeah you're exactly right uh we are just
living in a world where
the movies that we're getting are so
terrible that anything that's just
borderline okay is suddenly held as a
masterpiece you know that that's it like
it's it's Lowered Expectations and so
this is what you get you know movies
like maybe it's a really smart it's
maybe it's a really smart strategy from
the movie studios to just get
everybody's expectations so low that
they can lowball us with something
that's brilliant I mean I don't think so
because well it's not like they can't
produce good movies they were doing it
for decades but then if you look back to
like your favorite movies of all time I
I'm willing to bet that none of them are
um newer than about 20 years old
you know they're probably all from the
the the 2000s the early 2000s
um back through the 90s the 80s the 70s
um I don't think there'll be anything
from the past 10 15 years
because you know they've become lazy
they they've become lazy
um they have started relying on big tent
pool movies particularly remakes
particularly uh reboots of things
endless superhero movies you know that's
the been the money makers and it's just
inspired this culture of laziness in
them
what's going on with how many reboots
and remakes are happening at the moment
is it just that it's too much of a risk
to try and start a new franchise
I think it's
on paper doing a reboot or a remake of
something uh is it should be a winning
strategy because you should in theory
have instant access to that devoted fan
base you just want to see their favorite
property brought back
excuse me
uh and so financially it seems to make
sense the the problem is that
you can often capture lightning in a
bottle you know it something like
Ghostbusters classic movie we all loved
it back in the day uh it worked because
you know a bunch of really good creative
talents all came together had a great
script a great director everything just
worked perfectly
you know they tried to do it for the
second one back in the 90s uh yeah that
wasn't very good uh and then you got
Ghostbusters 2016. well we all know how
that turned out
we're gonna we're gonna repost it for
modern audiences uh capitalizing on the
Ghostbusters name and look what happened
it was a flop you know but it happens
over and over again but it's like
they're always trying to uh recapture
that lightning in a bottle from these
These past successes because
um well movies are expensive to make now
particularly if you're dropping 200
million dollars on a film damn man
that's a lot of money to invest you want
a pretty solid guarantee that it's going
to be successful and it used to be that
that was
you know that was a pretty good way of
doing it you know you can Market it as
we're gonna we're gonna bring back this
great franchise that we've got a huge
fan base for everyone will be happy
did you see that clip of Matt Damon on
first we feast or the hot hot wings
where he's talking about why modern
movies seem to be less adventurous have
you seen this clip do you know what I'm
talking about I I have yeah I guess it's
like he's uh he's crying while eating
this stuff
I don't know if this is like the
environment
yeah I don't know if this is almost like
how you inject people with like you know
truth serum and stuff like their mind is
so fogged by the pain of the the hot
wings that like they're just gonna spit
out straight on truths um I'm trying to
remember what exactly he said during
that he says that the death of DVD sales
has meant that movie studios can't be as
venturous anymore that you basically got
a second bite at the end of being able
to make money it might not win at the
box office but it can kind of be this
ascending underground Victory uh and he
uses this example of someone that said
it's gonna cost me uh 25 million for
this half of it goes to this I need to
double the spend on that so I need 100
million to make the money back and the
only way I'm going to do that is through
DVD sales what's your thoughts on that
yeah that's very true
um it was very much the long tail of
sales that would come after the
theatrical release and uh yeah there's
been plenty of movies that um you know
they didn't make their budget uh when
they were in movie theaters but they
ultimately became Pro profitable years
later just through DVD sales and all
that stuff
um so yeah there's absolutely something
to be said for that um
yeah it's it's I guess it's just a
different world you know
um with
streaming obviously that's radically
altered the equation
um you know the moment something gets
released onto streaming it's going to be
on on the high seas and that's going to
take a huge chunk of your Revenue as
well and people just getting it for free
um and yeah I guess there's just this
general climate of risk aversion you
know what is the things that makes money
at the moment
um the other thing I was going to say is
the the death of this or mid budget
movie they don't really exist anymore
you know there used to be a time when
you would get
your big you know Blockbusters that was
like 100 million dollar budget uh you
would get your little Indie movies that
were done for practically nothing but
then you would get in between films that
had like 20 30 million allocated to them
not a huge amount but then they don't
have to make a huge amount in order to
become profitable so I think that's been
a big change as well
one thing that I definitely hadn't
considered was that Harvey Weinstein
might have been the gateway drug or the
pebble at the top of the Avalanche that
caused Downstream from this for a bunch
of other problems to occur like I
understood that it is not particularly
popular at the moment to uphold men
particularly white men as being
competent in in the media
I didn't realize that this would be this
sort of pincer movement two-pronged
attack both coming from the internal
milieu that's happening inside of the
studios in the production World
generally and then also being fed back
up from what's happening in society as
well that's quite interesting
I think as well like we now are past the
time when writers in Hollywood actually
lived lives you know if you went back to
the the 70s and 80s uh in Hollywood the
these writers man most of them had lived
a life like they might have fought in
Vietnam or something uh they they
probably came from rough upbringings
they had to fight their way to get into
Hollywood and uh you know probably just
had interesting life experience that
they could bring forward to their their
writing on screen
um the writers that you get now
they would go into some
um you know
so that is that sound is I'm currently
in Austin Texas
and there's been a freeze storm
overnight which means that every tree
has got water on it which then freezes
and then the trees snap so I may go
outside of here and find that there's a
tree that's Fallen but the roof seems to
be okay at the moment so we will we will
continue all right we'll keep going well
as long as as long as you're alive we'll
keep going all right
all right um yeah so the writers now
like their career path is basically uh
either
um mummy or daddy is already in the
industry and so I get straight in or I
go to some liberal arts college where
I'm taught to hate you know white people
and and men and stuff for four years
um then get into Hollywood I say all the
right things uh about down with the
patriarchy and stuff and I just get
hired and so
um I don't have any life experience I've
never faced adversity I've never had to
struggle for anything in my entire life
and uh I don't know how to bring that
forward into my characters and so the
the things I know how to write about are
you're awesome the way you are because
you've already succeeded because I've
succeeded from from doing very little uh
and that's that's how they that's how
they rationalize life
um and so again
you know it all feeds into this this
culture I guess that we have now in
Hollywood of narcissism of selfishness
of
um you know
I'm the most important thing in the
world and I'm perfect uh and you know
it's not about improving yourself
anymore it's not about taking on
challenges it's just about everyone else
accepting you for what you are right now
I've also heard you talk about why it's
unpopular for men to be seen as stoic
anymore what's your insight though
well again yeah
um a stoic man is a toxic man in the
minds of Hollywood writers whereas I see
it as like a necessary
um survival skill really throughout most
of human history like you you can't have
everyone uh be high strung emotional
idiots who just go to PCS the moment
like things start going wrong there
needs to be stoic people who can deal
with problems
um logically and don't complain all the
time about things you know it's
people used to live Hard lives I guess
that's the the point I'm making previous
generations would be shocked and
appalled by how easy we have it now but
they they used to struggle and they used
to have to put up with a lot of hardship
and you develop stoicism as a result of
that that's what allowed you to deal
with it because you couldn't sit and
complain all the time because there was
no one to complain to you had to get on
and do things
um we don't live in that world now and
so that idea of stoicism the stoic man
um who who gets things done and who
doesn't complain about it
um that is seen as a toxic relic of a
different time and I think particularly
because of the the writers that you have
you've either got women
now in Hollywood
um who don't who are threatened by that
or you have effeminate men who've never
endured hardship uh who are envious of
that and so either side wants to destroy
it and get rid of it and mock it because
they don't understand it
um and so that's yeah that's what you
have now you don't get stoic male
characters they have to be constantly
joking they have to be constantly like
doing the the goofy um self-conscious
ironic humor about themselves they
usually have to mess things up like it's
just uh I don't know about you I just
that's not the kind of men that I've
known in my entire life like they they
don't act like that that's a caricature
Hollywood [__] version of what a man
is meant to act like
come up with
it's not accurate the way that women act
either most of the women that I know
especially the ones that I respect and
admire can deal with difficult things
they can go through exactly
and it's not it's not a unique yeah it's
not a uniquely male trait uh in the
slightest and you know it's not that uh
women would be expected to to be you
know super feminine and and uh you know
hyper emotional about everything not at
all
um there's usually a little bit of
sort of variation between them for sure
um but again their idea of like writing
a strong female character now is just
someone who's a total [__] who is
like super aggressive super domineering
wins every argument
never gets challenged on anything
um doesn't have any compassion or
anything for for other people uh again
that's that's not really how I've known
women to act
you use this really good example of the
animated Mulan movie compared with the
live-action remake that they did and in
the original one the girl that joins
this fighting force is smaller and
doesn't have experience and needs to
work incredibly hard to overcome her
physical limitations of being physically
smaller than everybody else and she has
to use Ingenuity and different tools and
she has to be smarter and she has to
work harder and that invests you in the
character I care about her outcomes
because an Underdog Story is one that
you're always going to resonate with and
then it comes to the live-action version
which is
a girl pretends to be a guy because
there aren't enough soldiers and then is
simply better than everybody else
because of some ineffable inherent
embodied
thing like super Chi fenge estrogen Chi
or something and because of the estrogen
Chi it means that she can win beat
people that have been doing it for much
longer than her that have worked harder
than her she doesn't have to go through
any difficulty or any challenge apart
from people
not believing in her primarily because
of her gender
and then she can save the day like
that's not an empowering story any woman
that thinks that that's an empowering
story for your daughter to have
doesn't have the same definition of
empowerment that I do
yeah that's it's the perfect example
really of the the kind of uh ridiculous
thinking that you have now in movie
making when it comes to ranked
characters like that like you say
the original gave you a great message
not just for little girls but for anyone
really like you might not always be the
strongest you might not be the fastest
or whatever
um but you can still Prevail through
through working hard through Ingenuity
through create creativity of those
things can can help you overcome uh
limitations
um but yeah the modern movie is
basically saying you have no limitations
you're amazing just everyone else needs
to accept how amazing you are uh it's
such a destructive message to give
people because life is meant to be about
improving yourself it's meant to be
about uh trying and feeling and picking
yourself up and doing better next time
that's that's the point of it
I learned a new word a couple of weeks
ago called fan baiting have you heard of
this
um
made a video about it in fact
did you really explain to people who
don't know what fan baiting is so in
Broad terms fan baiting is the idea of
um we're gonna create a new TV show or
whatever it's probably going to be an
adaptation or a remake of something that
you love uh what we're gonna do though
is we're going to race and or gender
swap most of the characters uh we're
gonna make a huge deal out of the fact
that we're doing that
uh and we're basically saying to the
fans of this this franchise hey we're
changing everything that you love
doesn't it make you mad don't you want
to don't you want to lash out don't you
want to criticize us go and do it do it
see what happens and that's what happens
you know people rise to the debate uh
they get mad about it inevitably some
people will go too far and they will be
genuine sexists or racist uh they'll say
things that are very inappropriate and
those people get
those comments that they make get caught
they get captured they get uh spread out
for everyone to see by the the actual
company that's doing this the studio and
they'll say look this fan base is toxic
the only people that hate this product
are racist and sexists uh you don't want
to be like that do you you don't want to
be one of those people you want to be a
good person you want to support the
thing that we're doing don't you support
it just just go along with it and that's
it that's what it is it shames people
into supporting something which is
fundamentally [__] it's fan being it
beats people into doing the thing that
they want so that they can they can
trump it as well we're just on the right
side here and everyone else who
criticizes our product is on the wrong
side
my soul is
there is only so far that you can push
people through guilt and shame to be
able to do something it's a an
interesting analogy with
some of the issues that came up in the
early 2010s when uh 50 Shades had done
really really well as a novel and the
dark romance genre generally was taken
off everything was great but there were
some concerns that uh the kind of
erotica novels that women were buying
were showing a very competent very
assertive very dominant protagonist in
the man so what they did was they tried
to replace those men on the front cover
with much more kind gentle more
agreeable less dominant men and guess
what they didn't sell well right the
heart wants what the heart wants what
can I say yeah dude your your money and
your arousal are two things that you
don't tend to give away without actually
genuinely wanting to and the fan making
things so fascinating we saw this with
what was that Bros boy what was it Bros
bros yeah Bros yes which I never watched
it but I know yeah yeah I know the
director basically was like you know if
you don't watch this you're bigger and
it's like that's just mask off like
straight up it's the equivalent of
basically getting down on your knees and
begging people to watch your your show
or your TV or your movie you know uh
it's pathetic and it's sad and it's just
it really exposed how bad that stuff was
so I understand
your rationale
saying that
um movie studios are concerned about
losing money which means that they do
something that they think is going to be
both socio-politically popular and
they're rebooting and remaking existing
franchises because that seems to be an
easier way to go but surely the type of
turnout that we've been seeing at the
cinema especially post pandemic right
which is going to have had a bit of an
impact but more so because movies don't
seem that compelling and if the director
is lambasting me for being too much of a
homophobe to go and watch a gay rom-com
that's that's definitely going to put me
off no matter my predilection around
that sort of a movie
surely studios are eventually going to
have to create things that people want
to actually watch or else they're going
to go broke like is there not hope in
the future that the market is going to
reform
these Production Studios into making
things that we actually want to see
yeah there absolutely is
um the thing you have to keep in mind is
that like all of this stuff has like a
three-year lead time
so like you're watching movies now that
are coming out in movie theaters they
were commissioned in like 2019
because you know it takes a long time to
make a film obviously like you know
you've got a scripter you've got to cast
people you've got a director thing
you've got to shoot the thing uh then do
all your post-production then get it on
its sleeve then get it marketed so
um in a sense what you're seeing in
cinemas right now are ideas from like
three years ago and that's why we're
still getting [__] movies that that do
all this stuff because probably
Hollywood has now recognized the the
mistakes that they made or they're
starting to recognize it uh and so that
they're starting to make those changes
to their Productions but that's not
going to come out for a couple more
years you know it takes time and this is
why you you often hear from people
saying it's gonna get worse before it
gets better because it probably will you
know
um Warner Brothers is a great example of
that
they have been losing money for years on
their their DC movies and stuff
um they brought in a guy called Walter
Hamada who was wanting to take it in the
the super walk Direction where you were
gonna do away with Superman do away with
Batman they were going to get replaced
by Supergirl and Batgirl
um and it was going to be them and
Wonder Woman like it was going to be all
female
um that I think they race swapped a
couple of them as well you know all of
that walk stuff just distilled into one
perfect triumvira of nonsense
um
he's been fired he he he's gone now they
brought in a guy called David zaslov he
looked at all this stuff that was coming
up and he was like [__] no and cancel
the whole bunch of it
um canceled Batgirl when it was made it
was ready to go they spent 100 million
dollars on this thing and he's like no
it's so [__] it's not even gonna get
shown ever it's gonna interval nobody
can ever see it ever you know in case it
in the lead and drop it at the bottom of
the Atlantic
exactly yeah I like burn it and salt the
ground and stuff but that's you know
that was that change of Direction
because they could no longer afford to
indulge this nonsense because they were
running out of money they had to bring
in a guy who was hard-nosed a
businessman who just uh hopefully had an
eye for making good quality films and
it's happened to them it's gonna happen
to other Studios as well
it just takes time lead time thing is so
interesting and I didn't think about it
at all I also know how long it takes to
make video games and that there is a
maybe a concern you're talking maybe
seven years between five and seven years
to make a you know a pretty good game
um I wonder whether computer games are
going to go that way as well I would
guess that the studios that make games
are a little bit more in touch with what
their core audience is after but you
know there was a new story part way
through last year saying that uh the new
GTA was going to feature lower rates of
violence and it was going to restrict
some of the things that you could do
which was going to be commenced with
more Progressive understandings of
social policy and the blah blah blah
they are going to get much more
immediate feedback from their fans
saying [__] no
than you can from a cinema I think yeah
it's like know your audience guys come
on you don't play a GTA game to be
politically correct you know I mean this
like uh yeah they've spent 20 years
allowing people to like shoot up entire
streets worth of people run [__] over
with cars you know Murder prostitutes
whatever all the like
um whatever depraved stuff people can
come up with you could probably do it in
those games
um but that that was just part of the
anarchic fun of them and so to try and
suddenly develop a social conscience now
it's like no that's that's not why
yeah you can't you can't just you can't
suddenly Rebrand yourself as a
responsible company like you know
um restricting all this stuff but yeah I
think the reaction was pretty severe um
and I think with gaming
um I'm trying to think what I can equate
it to
um there was some there was like the the
Battlefield games you know first person
shares and they tried to release one
called battlefield v a couple years ago
set you in World War II but it had uh
women fighting on the front lines with
cybernetic arms and stuff
um Asian men fighting in the you know in
the European Battlefield against Germans
um just you know ridiculous but it's
like they tried they put that in the
trailer they showed that stuff and the
reaction was apocalyptic like fans
absolutely I'm blambasted the game is
ridiculous uh and it sold terribly as a
result you know so that these things can
happen the backlash Works in some cases
what
what so going beyond the interjection of
race and gender and sexuality
it does also seem like there's a kind of
a negative very pessimistic tenor to a
lot of movies as well that they don't
seem to put across a lot of genuine hope
what do you think is going on there is
that reflecting what our culture is like
now is that impacting on culture is it
just the fact that we're coming out of
the back end of I don't know a period
where people aren't feeling too happy
I I think so I think uh it ties into
this idea of there's fewer just like
heroic Heroes I suppose
um and there's
not the kind of patriotic movies that I
think you used to get you know if you if
you look back to the 2000s particularly
you know
um for rather obvious reasons you know
America was fighting the war on terror
uh and so there was a need and a desire
for heroism for for pro-american movies
for
um you know for just patriotism and
that doesn't really exist now
um and again I don't know if it reflects
a kind of lack of confidence I don't
know if it reflects
um Hollywood's attitude to All Things
sort of American
um I I don't know if there's
weird associations there where it's like
they they feel like it's dangerous to be
be too you know Pro your own country I'm
not sure what the this the idea behind
it is but yeah I get what you're saying
in that uh there just doesn't seem to be
that optimistic view of like the whole
West the whole idea of Western culture I
suppose in movies but they'll repurpose
Fast and Furious 9 and Dumbledore
secrets of Albus or whatever it's called
to make it appropriate for a Chinese
audience
yeah it's interesting that isn't it when
money's involved
um yeah man I mean I've we've seen it in
ridiculous ways like they they try to
Market black panther to the Chinese who
aren't very keen on the subject matter
and so they they took Chadwick boseman's
face from the poster and put the Black
Panther mask on him so you couldn't see
what was underneath you're okay to make
it no they straight up did that they
erased him from his own movie to try and
make it more acceptable to Chinese
audiences and uh I thought the days of
Koto into China were done because
it seemed for a while basically all
Disney movies were getting banned there
they just couldn't get a release and so
you kind of thought well okay maybe
they'll just think [__] it uh if the
Chinese won't accept this anyway there's
no point trying to Pander to them let's
do something really crazy like be
pro-america
you know uh it's almost like we're an
American company and like our whole like
Walt Disney's entire outlook on life was
um like a fondness for all things
Americana you know he was a patriotic
guy he loved America
um be nice if they could live up to that
but nah they seem to have struck some
kind of deal I think now that um
Bob Iger is now back in charge they seem
to have smooth things out with the
Chinese government and I've heard I
could be wrong but these are the rumors
that uh all the Marvel cast all the
Marvel actors are now being
um sent on little training programs to
teach them what's acceptable to say
about China so that they don't say
anything an offensive you know they
don't mention Taiwan or anything like
that so no one does a John Cena again
yeah exactly and it's just John at the
front you walk in and you've got Chris
Hemsworth and you've got Robert Downey
Jr and then stood at the front in a
teacher's outfit you've just got John
Cena don't end up like me John Cena
these entrance music that's what I'm
about oh yeah I boy that speech that he
had to give uh and fearful fair play for
him you know to be able to speak
Mandarin but uh to have to basically
grovel uh and and plead forgiveness
because he dared to suggest that Taiwan
was a country
um my God it was one of the most
humiliating things I think I've ever
seen and I just think imagine if that
happened back in the the 80s or 90s
you know what I mean like that would
never have happened but now this is the
world that we live in so
yeah I mean so I I it's it's hilarious
and I've spoken about it a ton and it is
embarrassing and cringe-worthy and
evidently just straight up capitalism in
its worst form
however
if there was the risk of the entire
Studio that you were with and all of
your cast members and all of the people
that you'd worked with and every single
person basically having 50 of 30 or
something of their revenue hanging on
whether or not you're prepared to say
something in Mandarin for 90 seconds the
pressure is absolutely astronomical I I
still think it's a super cringe-worthy
thing to do but the situation in which
you wake up that morning and re get the
message from your manager or the studio
saying hi mate you shouldn't have said
that about Taiwan we need you to fix
this there is a lot of pressure
I I think in that specific instance
because the movie was made with the idea
that it was going to get released in
China and so like it would have been
budgeted for that and so on okay there's
not much you can do like if you've
screwed up you're gonna have to try and
fix it whatever way but uh you have to
ask yourself you know if you're actually
planning your movie in the first place
um what's your better strategy here is
it
you know we we uh forego any kind of
American patriotism and we kind of like
incorporate weird
um sort of pseudo-communist like
messaging into our movie to make it
acceptable to China so we get like an
extra 20 revenue or
do we go super patriotic for America and
for like pro-western culture
and get like an extra 30 or 40 because
people actually love uh what we've done
over here I know which way I'd rather go
you know I mean like I know which would
be my preference but that's just me
Game of Thrones finished the main series
finished and pretty much everybody was
disappointed with it which is a shame
because your availability bias is always
going to cause you to remember the most
recent part of it you know if it if it
had a [__] season five and it then come
back and smashed everything after that
then we might have more fond memories of
it
um how many seasons of House of the
Dragon do you think it's going to take
for people to feel fondly again about
the Game of Thrones franchise because I
certainly know as a huge Game of Thrones
fan that after the first season of House
the dragon being really really enjoyable
I thought it was really cool uh it has
dampened at least probably 50 of my bad
feelings toward that entire sort of
organization what's your thoughts I
think we're almost there actually yeah I
think uh season one of House of the
Dragon was really good it surprised a
lot of people it surprised me I I
predicted it was going to be pretty [__]
uh but it turned out to be really good
really smart really well done uh I think
a good season two will cement it
and I think people will be back invested
in the world of Game of Thrones it's not
like people aren't going to suddenly
think that uh season eight was great all
of a sudden and that's still a terrible
thing but they will at least be invested
in the world of Westeros again
um so I think as long as they don't
screw up season two uh they're they're
laughing and yeah I must admit it's a
great comeback story nobody expected
this yeah
I agree man I
it's the steaming pile of turd that was
season eight can't be extinguished this
late that's already been burned to a
crisp and like you say salted the Earth
afterward but uh yeah I mean that's good
I listened I've actually just finished I
think it's called a world of Ice and
Fire oh whatever whatever the prequel
book is that this series of House of the
Dragon is based on so I got super into
it and I said oh I'm gonna get the book
and listen to it one bad thing has been
that I now know everything that happens
in season two three and four because
obviously I wrote the book uh but I'm
also super excited because season two is
way more exciting than season one which
is pretty cool uh another thing yeah
which I thought was a real surprise
Victory another uh airplane watch was
bullet train
yeah
I thought was absolutely phenomenal
just a good good fun um action comedy
you know uh didn't take yourself too
seriously it didn't demand too much and
I I've you know I've said this many
times on my channel there's a lot to be
said for a simple concept well executed
and I think bullet train just does that
perfectly nice easy movie to watch
um does have some smart like moments in
it with like how uh things are set up in
the early parts of the movie and then
they get paid off later on I thought the
characters were really good
um really good fun
um I loved orange Tangerine
um yeah everyone loves Tangerine in that
movie
it had that um it had that kind of
snatch slash Lock Stock slash yes uh
very much
yeah style to it
uh yeah very much did uh it was kind of
uh yeah I want more movies like that I
want guy Richie to start making good
movies again
um but yeah uh I think it was just uh
yeah well executed movie
um didn't demand too much from anyone
and uh yeah I enjoyed it it was nice it
had no messaging in it either so that
was nice
steady away and also I mean it's
racially representative there was a a
big black guy that like Thomas the Tank
Engine there was a bunch of Asian people
in there there was a bunch I I have no
I I kid you know I have now started to
perceive the world in terms of Thomas
the Tank Engine yeah look at someone
someone who's been a total [__] it's
like you're a diesel yeah
yeah okay I I don't think I know my
Thomas the Tank Engine law isn't
sufficiently deep for me to actually be
able to use that effectively but maybe
the secret philosophy that I need to
work out so something that I was
disappointed by again from a plane
Journey uh was Jurassic world Dominion
what went wrong
everything I mean
all of these Jurassic World movies are
terrible as far as I'm concerned they're
all dumb uh they're all derivative
they're just recycling the same ideas
that we had in the very first movie in
1993 I remember being a little kid and
going to see Jurassic Park and I thought
it was amazing and it still is amazing
um but yeah it's just a peak example of
our lack of ideas our Hollywood's lack
of creativity we're just gonna recycle
the same stuff over and over again
um so yeah
the the whole concept of like the
dinosaurs and stuff is played out
um bringing back the original cast was
just a desperation move because they
knew no one was going to care about this
movie but the moment you say well you
know Alan Grant and Ellie and um and Ian
Malcolm they're all going to be together
again on screen you know there's a
little bit of interest there but they
were so underused it was really clear
that the script had no idea what to do
with them they're just wandering around
looking confused most of the time uh so
yeah man it was just uh it was a
desperation move to to try and milk a
bit more money out of the Jurassic Park
franchise
um there was not an ounce of creativity
behind it
um and just monumentally done
um I even though I think back to like
the stupid Locust plague and everything
I just think that that
didn't get an ounce of development it
was just a random idea that someone
threw in awful yes it does seem really
lazy I mean I have
driven an ATV a four-wheel ATV through
the valley that the first ever
helicopter shot coming into today
it I've driven an ATV through that
Valley in Hawaii and it was sick it was
me on my own traveling on my own and a
ton of Chinese tourists and I was
screaming that theme tune to myself
so I have very fond memories of the
Jurassic Park franchise you get to go
through
um what was the genetically engineered
dinosaur from the First new one
indominus Rex yeah
yes so you know it's got the scratch
marks on the inside of the wall where it
tried to get out you can drive your
little ATV through the door that's open
and you go through and I'm like this is
like this is really cool and I do have
fond memories of that first one but it's
gone very quickly downhill they're kind
of force-fed this random extra mother of
the daughter that the daughter's not her
daughter it's a clone of her back into
the film even though nobody mentioned
her for the entirety first thing and of
course she was secretly the one who
developed everything all the technology
behind Jurassic Park it's just no one
thought to mention her back in the day
and it's like yeah classic retcon
example it's like how dumb do you think
we are
what can you tell people the story of
what happened with uh Superman's lip
when he was the most
recently I learned this from you I
learned this from you
uh to this day I kid you not I could
look at pictures of Henry Cavill with
that fake lip and it makes me laugh but
um
okay the the short version is they had
done the original version of Justice
League Zack Snyder was directing it uh
the studio were unhappy because
um his previous movies hadn't done well
they wanted to lighten the tour and they
wanted to make it funnier all that stuff
um he couldn't do it and then he was
forced to drop out the project because
of a family
um tragedy
so they brought in Joss Whedon to
lighten the tone and he was basically
told fix this movie turn it into the
Avengers
and so that was going to require
extensive reshoots you know they were
gonna have to bring her back all the
actors shoot like you know loads of new
footage uh to try and fix this movie and
make it fun and and upbeat and all that
uh so they they brought back Ben Affleck
who was in the middle of a divorce and
he was alcoholic at the time he hadn't
trained in months and so he was about 30
pounds heavier uh looked like a
completely different person so he was
brought back in he literally his face
changes from scene to scene like it's
weird
um and they also brought back Henry
Cavill who was in the middle of shooting
Mission Impossible Fallout
um and he'd grown a sweet sweet Tash for
that one
um which was great
um but the
I think it was Paramount who did it they
wouldn't um give him permission to shave
off his mustache so that he could wear a
fake one so he could do these reshoots
um so the only option was
get him in Superman costume
um with his mustache and everything and
then we'll just digitally remove it
later but again because everything was
done to these insanely tight time scales
they didn't have time to do it properly
and so you've just got this ridiculous
mismatched mouth with like lips that
don't line up and uh it's it's one of
the saddest things I think I've ever
seen but it's also hilarious
I can't wait until the day when I have a
job where I've got a contractually
obliged mustache I feel like that
I just love because he could so easily
have worn a fake mustache and it would
look 100 convincing like actors do it
all the time but I honestly feel like
the studio just wanted to be dicks and
said yeah
you stick the middle finger up to DCU
absolutely yeah it's Warner Brothers nah
you're gonna have to spend millions of
dollars removing that and I always laugh
a bit upper lip and I always laugh
thinking like there's CGI artists that
signed up for this movie thinking we're
going to be rendering crazy like alien
battles and Landscapes and explosions
and stuff and and instead they're told
nah you've got to work on Henry cavill's
lips
oh you're the Henry cavill's lip
Department
yeah
congratulations on working on your first
DC Universe movie uh you're going to
take on a very very important role here
at you and Henry cavill's upper lip are
going to become intimately familiar with
each other and I need you to remove it
frame by frame thank you I mean maybe
maybe they did a really [__] job and so
like uh you know they did it on purpose
almost it's like we've been given the
worst role in the entire movie we're
just gonna absolutely screw it up I
don't know uh but yeah it's it's a great
piece of Cinema lore
yes I also learned another piece of
Cinema law from you that Nick Cage was
going to be Superman briefly was he was
yeah not so briefly for like three years
I think he was attached to it
um yeah this was a piece of legendary uh
failure on Hollywood's part they wanted
to do another Superman movie they wanted
to cast a new edgy you know cool actor
and Nick Cage was like super cool at the
time uh it's hard to believe now but he
was uh and so yeah he was attached to
the project
um it was gonna have Tim Burton
directing it uh unfortunately Tim Burton
came in and decided he wanted to change
the entire script it dragged on for
years and eventually the studio
interfered too much Tim Burton walked
away Nick Cage walked away the whole
project failed and I think they spent
about 30 million dollars on a film that
they didn't shoot a single frame of
footage on
incredible waste of money
but there it is
what's even better is like if this movie
had gone into production the plan was
that they were going to have a tie-in
with the Joel Schumacher Batman movies
at the time which was the George Clooney
one
um so you were gonna have Nick Cage
George Clooney
you know fighting crime together uh and
potentially even leading into a Justice
League movie and I just think that would
have been fantastic Goofy
that would have been a good competitor
for whatever the the non-schneider cut
thing was that they ended up doing
I honestly yeah yeah when I think about
how safe and boring and Bland movies are
now especially superhero ones I think
something like that would be so [__] but
so amazing at the same time
yes yes I don't know man I mean the DCU
generally is just
I've never got into it I've never ever
ever felt as compelled and I mean you
know like Marvel's whatever what is it
now uh generation four
for Marvel the phase five they're into
now yeah phase five I mean that that was
bad end game really was kind of the end
game of all of the stuff that was good
about that but
I mean that period that we had we were
so spoiled when you actually look back
at that yeah there was some kind of
Misses but for the most part that was a
really great series of superhero movies
big budget quite classic storylines
compelling protagonists good enemies uh
you there's there's humor in there but
it's not stupid there's role models in
there but they're not patronizing it was
great and then yeah it feels like we
blew our loads very soon it was like the
premature parade for the early 2010s and
now uh we're left in this sort of
wasteland looking for scraps on the
floor
yeah I I think um
it may be the superhero movies are now
moving into the parody phase which is
generally the last phase of a genre
before it dies off
uh and I'm fine with that we've had 20
years of this stuff now kind of ready
for something else to to you know take
the center stage in Hollywood
um but yeah whatever whatever Marvel
became you know however much they they
were probably victims of their own
success and they've eventually gone off
the rails
um we'll see if they maybe pick up in
Phase five but they at least flew before
they crashed and burns like whereas it
feels like DC never got off the ground
and it's frustrating because they had
without doubt the best characters you
know before all of this before Marvel
took off who the hell had ever heard of
Iron Man or the Guardians of the Galaxy
outside of the like comic book industry
outside of like people who are really
into that stuff who had ever heard of
any of those characters who had heard of
you know Captain America or anything but
everyone had heard of Superman everyone
heard of Batman everyone heard of Wonder
Woman DC had those characters they had
them ready to go they could have been a
genuine
alternative to Marvel you know just some
something on the same level if not even
bigger if they'd been properly managed
but they left it too late they tried to
play catch up they rushed everything
they screwed it up turn up time after
time
um and we're constantly trying to fix
their mistakes without understanding
what the mistakes were
I think the the DC on film over the past
10 years that's going to go down as one
of the biggest wastes of talent and time
and money and potential in all of Cinema
history
what about this Fallout from Justin
Roiland recently so for the people that
don't know one of the two writers
creators
from Rick and Morty uh has been popped
for some pretty incriminating text
messages to both women and girls uh it
seems like he's got an alcohol problem
and this has been going on for quite a
long time and it seems to be pretty
widespread he's kind of part of this
I've called I've been calling it the uh
the second me too or the internet me too
with Andrew Callahan from channel five
uh Chris Delia with the crystallia
problem documentary that just came out
uh Justin Roiland you've got this sort
of new wave of
guys that have kind of been popped by
this
um
it seems like Rick and Morty had already
started to lose some of its core fan
base in any case some people felt it was
falling off the wagon I feel like this
might be a
final nail in the car yeah man I I agree
like I watched the first few seasons and
I wasn't transpired it was super clever
witty edgy you know just great fun great
um great sort of sci-fi comedy uh I
think it it as it developed it became
more mainstream and so it started to
preach the message which is you know
obviously I've talked about a lot on my
channel
um and it started to turn people off
because it's like it just became a
sellout really
um and with royland yeah man like not
only have you lost 50 of your writing
team but you've also lost literally the
voice for Rick and Morty so I don't
really understand how the show is meant
to continue without him
you know
it's just uh I forgot I [__] forgot
that he voices
of the two characters how are you gonna
it's like yeah you're Rick and Morty how
can we how can we have Rick and Morty
without Rick and Morty like well you're
not gonna be able to uh Two and a Half
Men your way through by just swapping
out one of the protagonists with this
one he he is the protagonist
that's it yeah I mean you you probably
get a voice actor who can approximate
his his voice but like people are gonna
know it's not the same and yeah man I
just think this is the final nail in the
coffin for Rick and Morty I think it's
just done
I'm gonna shame what is coming out that
you are most excited about over the next
couple of years
uh so absolutely nothing uh I hate all
of modern Cinema and I want it to die
[Laughter]
no I mean I I joke
um probably Dune two I'll be interested
to watch that because I very much
enjoyed the first one and uh yeah I
think that's uh that's hopefully gonna
be good you know I've read the book and
uh and loved it like as a teenager so
it's it's nice to see a good adaptation
on screen uh so something like that God
I'm trying to think of anything else
really that's exciting me nothing from
Marvel I care about oh [__] have you
seen uh have you seen severance
no people have been recommending that to
me though
so I've seen one episode in I'm only one
episode in uh for the people that
haven't heard about this I don't even
know what it is at the moment it's I
guess I guess
sort of Science Fiction need drama it's
about uh people that go to work at a
particular place and they can't take
their memories from inside of work
outside or from outside inside and they
have to sign this contract and uh I'm
only one episode in I was pretty
enthralled by it to start with because
there's a lot of questions why if these
people agreed to this job all of the
jobs that seem uh really kind of
pointless you don't really understand
what's going on so there's just a lot of
questions so that's that's definitely
that and the last of us
um are two things that have been
pretty impressed by recently but looking
forward uh the the future and sadly I
fear might be as Bleak as you're saying
I don't know of anything really apart
from watching uh Harry Potter Hogwarts
Legacy playthrough videos on YouTube
there isn't much that I've been uh
ridiculously excited by
I mean I'll be ex I'll be happy to watch
uh Cobra Kai season six because I think
that's gonna be the final season
um House of the Dragon season two I'll
be I'll be interested in the next
stranger things because that that's a
show that really redeemed itself as well
that really came back from the brink uh
so probably TV is going to be the more
exciting thing for me I guess
yeah yeah it's um that's been what's
salvaged a lot of uh I mean look at my
watch time like if I go on and you go
into Netflix I'm not going on to movies
if I'm struggling you know when you're
deep in the Netflix hole desperately
trying to find something I'm going into
either documentaries or series I'm just
never going into movies because I very
very rarely find a movie that just makes
me feel satisfied or gives a payoff at
the end but yeah I'm I have hope despite
the incredibly despondent uh way to look
to the future I do have hope with this
whatever you want to say like the
drinkers lagging hypothesis or the
production lagging hypothesis that
you've come up with which is in three
years time one one thing I do want to
know actually is you said that parody is
the final
stage of a cycle of a genre is this a a
well understood
yeah I I I think uh it's generally seen
as I can't remember who wrote it
originally but it's the genre theory
that I think there's four stages to it
so the first stage is like the the early
kind of you know prototype stage of a
genre like the ones that become
breakthrough movies and clue people into
the idea that uh it can be a viable
thing uh then you've got like the
um maturity stage where um it's uh
it kind of reaches its golden e Golden
Age like where like ideas start to
mature uh they get really good at
producing the movies then you've got the
um deconstruction phase where they start
to explore
you know different ideas like they're
they're always looking for new angles on
this genre uh and then last of all you
got the parody phase so it's kind of
like we we Pioneer it we perfect it we
um Tinker with it and take it apart and
then we just have a laugh at it and mock
it and then we're done that's that's
four stages of
Iron Man
into the most of the MCU from the 2010s
into end game into Thor love and Thunder
yeah
I would say that would probably be your
you're your best way of looking at it um
you can you can kind of apply it to the
Western genre that's what the user good
example you know your early ones would
be your John Wayne movies uh then you
get your you know your your
um
sort of classic ones with him uh and
then you get your sort of Clint Eastwood
Spaghetti Western ones which is like the
deconstructed hero uh and then you get
your parody ones like Blazing Saddles
and stuff like that and then it's just
done you know so uh yeah we're at the
party phase now I feel like with
superhero movies like whether it's
intentional or not like most Marvel
movies are just parodies now
um of of what they once were and I'm
more than happy for that genre to to
wind up now and just we can move on to
something else because get really tired
of reviewing superhero movies
and I imagine I imagine that you can be
yeah taking it out back and putting a
bolt in its head might be a a good idea
look drink it dude I really appreciate
you where should people go if they want
to check out more of your stuff your
YouTube's absolutely fascinating so
everyone should go and look at that
yeah uh so I'm obviously I'm producing
new YouTube videos on both my channels
like every couple of days I do live
streams every Thursday night on open bar
um you can find me on Twitter as well
and I've also got a bunch of stuff that
I'm working on at the moment uh I've got
a whole bunch of novels that I've
written called the Ryan Drake series uh
and I've got a comic that's uh recently
come out and it's through Indiegogo that
you can order that so that's called a
new kind of War uh so those are all the
things I'm working on right now and also
a short movie that I'm
producing so that's been fun as well
busy guy yeah excited for you
thank you
all right man thank you for your time
today
cheers what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]